[Music]
we're not ones to fall
and stay on the ground we get up
we're gonna show y'all what one love
really means
[Music]
basketball is something that really
allows people to come together
no matter what background you are it
just creates a good
form to open up conversation and create
a bond right away we're serving that
here today
we're just still being out here tomorrow
and we're serving that here for the rest
of our
[Music]
lives
the job that i do is like i'm a
community activist and a basketball
architect and i always try to
evolve like james nate smith's vision
for basketball
the who bus is something that was
cooking on my brain for about 10
years what if we kind of renovated a
school bus and turn it into a basketball
traveling machine
found this beautiful bus collecting dust
in the middle of the palm desert
their mission is to rebuild basketball
courts all over the country with a
message
to end racism the entire mission of the
hoot bus is to bring people together
uniting them through basketball art and
fashion
we felt called to dedicate the bus to
the black lives matter movement
i have faced racial injustice in america
i have been racially profiled
i have been falsely accused and arrested
and gone to jail and had to fight for my
freedom so i know what it feels like
we all have this message that we want to
get across a message of positivity
a message of love we are basically the
freedom writers of 2020.
the idea for the road trip was sparked
by our goal of traveling the country
and building communities the march on
washington which was publicized
after the killing of george floyd for us
felt like a monumental task that we
could build towards
in each one of these stops we're going
to be spreading a message of love and
unity through basketball
we want to do what we've done in la and
spread it across the country
we want to come show support and
solidarity to start connecting and start
having conversation
and just realize that really basketball
is the common story and it really unites
for this store we had to install bunk
beds outdoor showers
ac system we replaced the indoors with
hardwood floors
we changed the seating area so people
can face each other and it's more
conversational
for a project like this to come together
it's all about the people involved
the diversity amongst us is phenomenal
we have people from
every different background we've been
almost all the way across the country
now
starting off in l.a where the whole
buses originated venice beach california
hit redlands for a small protest palm
springs phoenix arizona
albuquerque new mexico dallas texas we
went to houston texas went to new
orleans on bourbon street batesville we
went to birmingham
atlanta georgia charlotte north carolina
raleigh north carolina then
washington dc this is an event that was
kind of announced through social media
even in small towns there's like 100 200
people people already know about the who
bus is
incredible it's already become just like
vehicle of change
one of the main things on our trip was
written proving courts
one of my favorite moments was in dallas
we built a court
for a community and it was phenomenal
like these guys really came to our
community
our little community where nobody comes
they talk to us they shook our hands and
they build a whole court for us
just to see the excitement and the joy
that the kids had
that makes an impact even after we leave
i mean we pull up the cities and we you
know play some basketball and we have
conversations and then we go to the next
city
but i think that we were able to really
make a lasting impact in that community
in oak cliff
being in atlanta has been amazing it was
definitely one of the spots when we were
looking across the map like where do we
want to stop it was atlanta 100
it's a huge huge culture spot for civil
rights
there's so much history in atlanta first
stop we pulled up to was a john lewis
mural
and when you stand underneath it and we
get to look up i mean you're just in awe
of him and what he represents
in civil rights history stopping by
martin luther king jr's birth home
uh and standing on those steps besides
just the hoop bus being there i think
being there as an individual is really
impactful
this city is the most important to me
being born northside
hospital atlanta georgia raised in
marietta georgia literally playing
recreational ball right up there in that
gym knowing all the black excellence
that is in atlanta and being able to
bring the who busts here
myself i can tell my daughter years from
now your father did something positive
beyond basketball
something big that would last forever
that these kids out here will see
forever they be like when i get older
i need to do that too
everybody put their fish in and we're in
this together we came a long way
together the march taking place
here in washington 57 years to the day
after martin luther king jr
gave his eye of a dream speech if you're
looking for a savior
get up and find a mirror we must become
the heroes
of the history we are making to come to
washington
to be able to walk in the shoes behind
the trailblazers like martin luther king
57th anniversary before i have a dream
it's
amazing the freedom riders that were in
1961
really showed that example of standing
for something
let's finish this together too it's not
over if people have the power
we gather together we can do anything
build courts
we dedicate a court a court that has a
nod
to the great dr martin luther king jr
change communities we want to see change
happen and we want to see justice
we won't rest until we do there's a knee
upon the neck of democracy
and our nation can only live so long
without the oxygen of freedom
i have a dream as well to you know help
change the world and to make the world a
better place
[Music]
the strength must be exercised by more
than reddit
and more than marching it's a full
global civil rights movement
we're on this journey together and it's
not over
57 years later still a lot of work to be
done
as the civil rights movement is moving
forward like the bus is following
we have only just begun our journey has
not ended yet
we will continue amplifying the voices
of the unheard it's not a moment
at all going into the communities and
let the world know that
these are the people that make america
great carry on on three
one two three